our last call before the break was a guy
that was in a couple of car leases we
call them fleeces and if you don't know
what that means that means you're not
from the country if you have a sheep and
you fleet you take off its hair
it's called fleecing and if you are to
fleece someone it means to rip someone
off it's old-fashioned terminology so if
I got fleeced means I got ripped off so
we don't call them car lease as we call
them fleeces and Robert is on Twitter he
says I listen to you every day can you
discuss leasing a car as opposed to
buying yes I can discuss fleecing now
let's just set this up for a second
let's pretend that you owned a car
manufacturing company and you were going
to manufacture a vehicle and you had a
car that you are going to sell for
twenty thousand dollars and four years
later it was going to be worth 70
percent less art was gonna lose about
fourteen thousand dollars of its value
and so that $20,000 vehicle four years
from now would be worth six thousand
dollars that would be the average by the
way new car loses sixty to seventy
percent of its value in the first four
years it has comes off a lot and so
instead of selling it for twenty
thousand dollars and the individual
that's driving it loses the fourteen
thousand dollars instead you're gonna
rent it to the individual that's driving
it and at the end of the car lease
you're going to not get a twenty
thousand dollar car back you're going to
get a car back that's worth six thousand
dollars well in order to keep from
losing the money you would have to rent
the car monthly to that individual for
more than that monthly amount of loss
and so if we just took $14,000 and we
just in our example and we said that
happened over 48 months that would be
291 dollars and 67 cents that the car is
going to lose in value in our projection
now you and I would you own a car
manufacturing company and so you're
gonna rent a car to someone that's going
to lose two hundred ninety one dollars a
month in value and so it stands to
reason that you're going to rent the car
to them for more than two hundred ninety
one dollars right because you at least
have to cover how much it goes down in
value in the payment in the rent payment
does that make sense of course it makes
sense then the other thing you know is
that if you own a car manufacturing
company you probably also have a
financing arm to your car manufacturing
company and if you're in the car
manufacturing business and you had
General Motors credit or Ford Motor
Credit or Lexus credit you would know
that you make more on the financing when
someone uses your financing company and
pays you interest to borrow money from
you that you make more on that than you
do on the actual profit on the sale of
the car and so you also are in the
finance business the banking business
the car payment business and you make a
good profit on that and so if you rent
this car to someone they're not going to
be paying you interest so you're going
to lose out on the car payment business
side of your equation and so not only
would you want to collect two hundred
ninety one dollars plus a profit you'd
also want to collect interest on the
twenty thousand dollars that basically
they're driving around your twenty
thousand dollar bill right here right I
mean you gave somebody twenty one
thousand dollar bills and they're
carrying them around for four years so
you'd want to charge them interest on
that wouldn't you
and so you would take the drop in value
monthly
you would take a interest rate which in
the leasing business is called cost of
capital and interest rate and you would
take a profit and you would put all of
those things into what is now a new
payment and then you can go rent a new
car for a Renault I'm sorry lease a new
car rent it is renting isn't it so when
you rent a car when you lease a car you
are paying the loss in value monthly
you're paying the profit and you're
paying and interest rate the cost of
capital the only thing is the interest
rates not disclosed to you because this
is not technically a loan and so the
Federal Trade Commission disclosure
sheets that you get on a loan are not
there because you're technically just
renting and so when you rent at Hertz
you don't have to get a disclosure on
the cost of capital and when you lease
from Lexus or BMW you don't have to get
a cost of capital so unless you're
pretty good with a calculator you really
don't know what your cost of capital is
you don't know what interest rates
you're paying I'm pretty good with a
calculator though and a lot of other
people are - that have done research on
this and we're finding that the average
car fleece out there is charging you an
effective interest rate a cost of
capital around 14% so you're paying
around 14% interest plus you're paying
the loss in value that appreciation plus
you're paying a profit and if you go
over on your miles they're going to
charge you more and if there's more than
normal wear and tear on the car they're
gonna charge you more because if you
bring me back a six thousand dollar car
that's dinged up and got a bunch of
miles so it's really only worth five
thousand I'm gonna charge you the other
thousand if I'm the car manufacturer
because my goal here is not to lose
money my goal is to make money and so
there's no possible mathematical way
unless the car manufacturer made a
mistake
that leasing a car is cheaper than
owning a car by definition it has to be
more expensive or you have a car
manufacturer that's what's known as
stupid and let me tell you those guys
are a lot of things but stupid is not on
the list most car manufacturers these
days make a really fine vehicle I drove
one of the new Fords as a rental this
weekend an expedition and it was an
incredible car the technology is it's
absolutely incredible
the new BMWs the new Mercedes the new
Chevrolet's they're absolutely
phenomenal the new Lexus they're from
not the cars that we are putting out in
America and around the world right now
are absolutely incredible vehicles
they're excellent at manufacturing and
really good cars I mean compared to I've
got a I've got an old Corvette from 1979
model they don't make them like they
used to well thank God I mean it's kind
of cool but let me tell you compared to
the new Corvette it's a piece of crap
these are fine vehicles these
manufacturers are creating you work for
a car company you should be proud of the
product you're putting out these
Nissan's really good cars they're also
very good at crunching numbers and math
and they're a hundred percent sure
they're gonna make money on your butt as
the consumer so let me tell you about
fleecing a car 100 percent of time it's
more expensive than owning the car it
has to be by definition it has to be by
definition hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]